you're watching steampunks the GameSpot
show where we go through steams new
releases and pick out some of the hidden
gems that you may or may not have picked
up normally yeah I'm Edmund Tran and
there was a focus on hidden gem which is
why as good as Far Cry 5 and you know
Cooney happened to be in they're both
very good good playing a lot of Far Cry
5 yeah but you won't hear about those
games on this show because we want to
tell you about some games you probably
haven't heard about all right just so
what you play this week alright so the
first game I got into was the game that
looks an awful lot like Vanna saga but
it's called ash of God's Redemption it's
got gorgeous graphics really interesting
turn-based RPG gameplay and it's kind of
got a lot of interactive narrative
elements sounds a lot like the Banner
Saga yeah so basically the game sets you
up with you have three protagonists and
the reaping is coming the reaping from
the reef is and basically the three
protagonist trying to save the world
yeah look so there are a lot of
narrative elements in this game that
come off like a little bit cheesy or
characters that feel a little
inconsistent
let me ask dude are these develop is not
of an english-speaking country I really
want to put a focus on that the
developers are Russian and I think a lot
of the occasional dialogue
inconsistencies where they're they often
speak in like a medieval manner and then
someone will just rock up and be like yo
we're up [ __ ] creek and it's like ha I
don't understand when you do get into
combat it's half turn-based and half the
use of cards which are kind of magical
artifacts that do certain things on the
battlefield and you're sending out a
group of heroes which is six people it's
nice to be able to chat to them at
campfires and along the interactive
narrative part of the game and build up
those relationships and I've played
about two hours now but I'd be really
interested to see how they develop your
lead protagonist the captain of your
entire party can just die in the game
keeps going so when you get into battles
you'll be expending health and energy
and
one of the things that takes some
getting used to is certain abilities
don't just cost energy but they can cost
health so trying to do like a massive
shot with your archer can knock down
half your health you have a choice of
whether to attack energy or health
attacking energy is really useful
because it stops them being able to do
their big nasty abilities and also if
you get their energy all the way down
you do double damage to health so there
is a traditional RPG framework
underneath all of this where you get
experience from battles on your
characters that you send in will be able
to level and will be able to take on
different abilities or get different
stat buffs as they go you can choose
where to go and where to go next and you
have random encounters on the way story
encounters that will sometimes affect
your party and I love a game that has
you make choices but you don't know what
the right one to do is or you can't just
like do the just thing and be rewarded
there are consequences to every action
and there is a huge focus on the fact
that every hero is really just a soldier
like no one is more important than
anybody else you know I'm a I'm a huge
banner soccer fan I absolutely love the
first two games I can't wait for the
next one so I'm inherently a bit
suspicious of this one yeah but if you
say it's good maybe I'll give it a shot
I think you should try it
so there's one thing I really enjoyed
doing it's driving and I love driving
games not so much racing but just
driving so this next one is exactly that
it's a game called jalopy it's been an
early access for a while but this week
it finally got it's at one point zero
really so congratulations to them so
this is a game set in I guess a
fictitious German state well it it's
Germany and there's actually your
Eastern European countries it's not
based on you know actual topography or
whatever the whole concept is you having
this car that is a [ __ ] box and you need
to sort of repair it maintain it and
basically go on a road trip with your
uncle across Eastern Europe and try and
keep the car running it's nighttime so
you start off by like getting this car
and it's got nothing on it and you'll
have to go through the processes of sort
of putting a door on it you know
installing the engine and the carburetor
and the air filters in the water and all
that kind of stuff you might like in
countersuit of petrol stations and
things along the way but your might also
run into a bunch of hazards on the
randomly generated map so you'll need to
keep some supplies so once you've got
your cars that have setup and stuff you
pick a destination on a map and while
you're driving you should take care of
the little things like do the handbrake
you know turn the key in the ignition
you'll be making like pit stops for fuel
and rest and that's where the other part
of the game comes in where it's like
making sure your car is maintained and
sort of earning money by collecting junk
and selling it at the shops if you do do
that if you do decide to stay legal
money can be an issue so you need to
scrimp and save or later in the game
being try and smuggle [ __ ] across the
border illegally to try and get more
stuff and the Ottoman goal is to help
your your uncle very early on you
discover that there's something more to
his reasons for wanting to take this car
across the country but yeah I'll leave
that for people to discover a bit I love
just enjoying the quiet moments on this
road trip and I don't know it's just a
very low stakes game it's currently 9
bucks on Steam and that's a sale price
because they just went to 1.0 it's
usually 15 bucks but even at 15 bucks
this is a great game and I just love the
little details and its general Eastern
European vibe
okay well for my second game is week my
first game there's so much to do
yeah and in this game there is a lot to
do but just in one particular place one
like and there wasn't a whopping there's
a lots to do in icon exactly so instead
of a car we're talking about a
surveillance system called all well so
this game is called all well ignorant is
strength it's the second installment in
the old world series where you work as
an agent to an advisor in the government
body that's called the office
within the nation and those names are
exactly as vague as they probably should
be because this is a game about
surveilling the people and the public
it's a very controversial system as you
can imagine it deals with privacy and
fake news you are combing through
people's Facebook pages their Twitter
pages of course they don't have those
names in the game but basically what
you're working with is the Internet much
like in in real world in this game all
these persons of interest put a lot of
information up on the internet you can
also get their phone numbers and hack
into their phones you can tap into their
phone conversations and then out of all
of that content will it be little data
chunks so something will come up that
it's highlighted like someone saying in
in a revolutionary blog oh I want to
take down the president so then that
will come up as a data chunk which you
can carry over and import into the
Orwell program and it will be acted on
so every single time you put a data
chunk in which is the only thing you do
in the game the game tells you this
cannot be undone so ignorant the
strength is separated into three
different parts you can pick up all
three for $10 what you basically want to
do is track what has happened to this
double agent person of interest and what
another person of interest is
threatening to do to the government I
think oh well is really interesting it's
not like anything I've ever played
before I also love games that ever let
you go through anyone's emails or like
personal correspondence and this game's
really good at not having hot scenes or
anything like that but really making
their people into people it's a really
interesting game to play and
I can't recommend it enough leave us out
of your plans Rabanne we want nothing to
do with them don't you understand
it's not my choice all right will you
play the game where you were browsing a
fake Internet hmm from a game you
download from the internet I played a
game on my PC about building pcs so I
played PC bowling simulator yeah and it
this is a freaking good game this
simulates the nitty gritty details of
building your own custom PC so yeah like
the Jalopy actually you'll be taking
individual this great part and like
plugging them into sort of a PC case so
you'll be like taking apart the case
like putting in the components screwing
in all the screws which is tedious but
not as tedious as it is in real life why
it all up properly and see for boots you
can't plug things into the wrong way
right and it will tell you if something
is missing the majority of the
components as far as I could see are all
based on real manufacturers components
right so I always find like MSI video
cards and I personally have and cool
master cases and that kind of stuff and
it does this amazing thing that once
you've bought the tutorial PC and booted
up it zooms into the monitor and it
becomes what's on your monitor so it's
like you're playing the game within a
game within the game so there's a
campaign mode where much like Jalopy you
are helping out your uncle Wow with his
failed computer shot so you'll be in
this little small space and sort of
answering emails and fixing people's
computer problems as they bring in their
cases so you'll be doing things like
yeah taking the PC diagnosing the
problem and then like installing new
software on it which is really hilarious
cuz you have to wait but I like the
virtual install times like the virus and
so program obviously a big part of
earning at PC store is actually buying
the components so there's like a whole
in-game online shop and yeah this is an
early access game just came out this
week I'm having a great time is it and
no I'm gonna play this a hell of a lot
more I think
[Music]
all righty that is everything we've got
for you guys this week do let us know if
we've missed any hidden gems that you
enjoyed on Steam or wherever else this
week I'm at Jess McDonald and I'm a dead
oven Tran and we'll see you with four
new games next week so let us know if
anything catches your eye see you later
[Music]
[Music]